a washington post investigation shows
that black people in the united states
are more likely more than
twice as likely i should say to be
killed by police as white people
george floyd's death is just the latest
incident this year
in march briana taylor was shot eight
times by police as she lay in bed
plain clothes officers entered her
kentucky home in the middle of the night
without warning
this month a sudanese-american man yes
muhammad was shot dead in georgia
after several encounters with police
advocates say he may have been suffering
from mental health problems
also in georgia police are accused of
delaying the investigation into the
killing
of jogger ahmed arbury because one of
the suspects has links
to law enforcement speaking out to avis
jones de weaver who's the president and
ceo of insight unlimited that's a
consulting firm focusing on race
gender and inclusion joins us on skype
from woodbridge
in virginia uh welcome to the programmer
so we have these victims that i've
talked about before there's
others as well armored aubry as we
mentioned there freddie gray eric garner
and more time and time again this
happens and there's lots of hand ringing
afterwards lots of promises for change
and then people
walk free and the world ends up
forgetting about it and on we go
until it happens again
yeah i i would say the world ends up
here
forgetting about it but black people
don't forget about it okay this is a
constant threat
that we live under in this nation and it
is very much front of mind
we understand that though we have built
this nation
and we've been a part of this nation for
over four centuries
that we've never been fully given the
free rights of citizenship
to be able to navigate this nation
using just our personal space in the
same way
that our white counterparts have uh
there is
nothing that anyone can tell me that
would convince me
that a white man would have been choked
to death
in the way that this particular murder
happened
and not first of all it wouldn't have
happened and secondly
if it were to happen it's unimaginable
that the murderers would still be
free and that's what they are murderers
every time this happens
people seem to say okay this is going to
be the moment that the real change will
come that we cannot take this anymore we
cannot accept it and and all the leaders
say the right things
but it doesn't happen as we as we've
already said but do you think this time
there could be a difference right
uh unfortunately i don't think so i have
no evidence to suggest that this time
will be different
um you know i look over the history
of this nation and we've been here
before we've been here
dozens of times before hundreds of times
before
thousands of times before really to be
perfectly honest
um black life clearly is cheap
in america and there is not the same
level of justice associated with the
murder of black people
uh in america than it is uh with
others and particularly with white
people in america
um and so though this is an outrage
and though people are definitely
responding to the outrage with i would
argue
justifiable rage
um the bottom line is i do not trust
this nation
to do what's right moving forward um
especially since they haven't
done the bare minimum in terms of what's
right with this case
and that the murderers are still welcome
free as i speak to you right now
right and do you think that these
protests i mean more
immediately do you think these protests
are minneapolis and now in other cities
do you think
uh they're just going to build in
momentum they're going to continue and
then
if charges are laid will that help quell
the matter
uh i believe that will help but you know
i have to
i have to tell you i'm really quite
concerned about why
no charges have been raised yet here's
one thing i know
for sure just based on pure good
old-fashioned common sense
truth can be expressed immediately
but it takes time to construct a lie
and i am concerned
that delay that's associated with
bringing charges
it's specifically because things are
being constructed
to make this ultimately kabuki theater
where the charges will not hold
and these people will walk through great
we've seen it before we've seen this
movie
before and it's been played over and
over again and so while an arrest
will be helpful we know the script
that's often run
um in in order to justify the loss of
black life and
i believe what we're seeing all across
this country
in relation to this particular murder is
a level of pent-up frustrating
frustration and rage
that says no more and though i'd like to
be optimistic that this time might be
different
uh you know i have to be i'm one of
those people
with this particular situation where i
have to see it to believe it because so
often i've been disappointed that i
really don't expect
anything anything different than what's
happened previously
avis jones did we we appreciate your
time and your analysis thank you
absolutely thank you